hmm not happening chicken banger okay
just going for the book yeah around here
at your 7:30
it's Allison change or nothing oh no no
what's your name bud hey I'm Blake I'm a
hard rocker too so I get it I'm married
but pirate hey thank you on buckets
we're all friends here no need for the
name-calling I'll feed Bower you know
what whoa I've got this you can't talk
to my friends that way that's fact yeah
yeah but I can pour this beer on your
head like that oh come on that's a
that's a perfectly good Molson hey no
sup yeah try that again and this is
gonna happen to your dick yeah that's
right that's your dingdong in two paces
oh I want you to hit me so bad right now
just hit me get out of here you
yes ma'am here yes yes ma'am now get out
of here you go you want to sing
something up no oh no no no come on
stupid we're gonna you know try you too
that's gonna bad Oh